(Christmas music)
(pen scratching)
- My name is Blake from North Carolina.
This year, I want football
gloves and a gold chain.
I want the gold chain
because I could look cool,
and look like...
I already look cool, but it's
just I wanna look cooler.
I wanna look drip, and so...
Yeah.
(audience cheering)
(Kelly laughing and clapping)
- So for those of you over 40,
drip means, like, an awesome
sense of style or swag.
You learn something new every day
here on "The Kelly Clarkson
Show," including myself.
Like we do every year, though,
this season we've paired up
with our season-long partner,
Pilot Frixion Pen, the go-to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show,"
to give Santa a helping hand.
And Blake, we want to
celebrate kids like you
creating fearless and
bold holiday wishlists,
so we're giving you $1,000
for gloves and a new necklace
to make you look drip.
(audience cheering)
And to everyone watching, remember,
you can pick up Pilot
Frixion erasable pens
wherever office supplies are sold.